Hi, my name is grant I'm bald, I'm British. And most importantly,
I don't have a beard because I'm not Simon just before we get into this video.
Let me thank today's sponsor. Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning community for creators,
with thousands of classes in design business, and.
More. We've.
Talked about Skillshare a few times on this channel and mentioned the various
courses and things you can learn on that platform,
but maybe you haven't got Skillshare yet,
and you are totally skill less like me.
That's a shame because there are thousands of classes on Skillshare for you to
level up your design business, video, social media, whatever skills,
or just take from them. Nothing. You can do that too.
Here in visual politic, we've taken to video production courses, camera courses,
YouTube type stuff for making the channel better.
We also want to squeeze out as much as possible from our date.
So we watched this course by a guy called Thomas Frank,
who is also a YouTuber on getting more stuff done in a day.
Great stuff is worth Jack and I, if you want more done out of your 24 hours,
but yes, Skillshare just go do it. You'll like it.
It's also free for two months,
so you can try it out and I'm pretty sure you'll continue your membership
because it is fantastic.
You can also support visual politics by supporting Skillshare.
There's a link below which will let you use the platform for two months for
free, as I already mentioned, but you guys know that I'm Scottish.
We love free stuff. So let's get into the video
Again. And what is almost an endless story? Korea is on fire.
It almost seemed that peace negotiations between North Korea,
South Korea and the United States.
We're on the right track yet far from claiming victory.
Things may have become complicated yet again. So my visual politic geeks,
the peace talks that have taken place in recent years have resulted in the
longest period of stability on the Korean peninsula and the last 20 years,
not since the days of the sunshine policy promoted by president Kim de Jong,
has there been as much positive news?
All this is thanks to this man.
The current president of South Korea Mingy and has made the approach to polling
young,
the main objective of his team in government or reaching out the ultimately
seeks the signing of a peace agreement that would bring a final ends to the
Korean war once. And for all,
because let's not forget this war has technically been ongoing since
1953. It's only buffered by a simple armistice,
much like the arguments between me and any girlfriend I've ever had.
The hold on a woman.
Because just no less than two years before he finishes his term and against all
the odds Mungy ends.
Dream of such political success may have been definitively crippled.
And the obvious question is what exactly happened to make those peace talks
suddenly blow up. Will moon have enough time to reroute dialogue towards peace?
What role does the United States Trump and the November election in the U S play
in all this mess and perhaps the most important question of all,
will we be witnessing the rise of a new leadership in North Korea and this
video, we will tell you all about it. So.
Listen up
the metaphor of a controlled explosion.
Before we start take a look at these images.
What you've done.
Seeing,
being blown to pieces is none other than the inter Korean liaison office,
a place that was established in September, 2018,
and that functioned in practice as a kind of embassy,
a place to meet and advanced negotiations between the two careers. However,
the communist regime decided on June 16 to 2020 to use a massive load
of explosives to blow this building to kingdom, come an explosion.
This symbolizes just how they do things and how they understand negotiations in
Pyongyang. This was the latest, bold move by the North Korean regime,
a move that began with the unilateral cutting of the telephone lane used by both
countries to speak and coordinate military and civilian matters.
North Korea cuts off all communication lines to South Korea, the New York times.
What it was the liaison offices explosion that felt like a real slap in the face
to [inaudible] government.
Basically it serves as a vivid depiction of how North Korea has blasted those
peace talks that had been underway for more than two years,
our turning point and a story and a Southern romance that to tell the truth was
a story that pong yang never quite.
And look.
Because this exclusion does not bear his signature.
It was not directly ordered by Kim Jong as is typical.
And as we might logically think, but by his little sister, Kim, you, John,
who we covered in a recent video about North Korea as possible political ears,
I'll leave that link to the video and the description. Hang on a minute.
His sister ordered the communication links to South Korea to be destroyed.
Something strange is going on.
Don't you think that is unless you have a little sister,
in which case you understand how destructive that can be.
We'll get into that in a moment though.
But first we have to take a look at what on earth has caused North Korea to
destroy all of the progress made over the last two.
Years.
What it all amounts to some helium balloons.
This whole mess has been caused by some helium balloons. Seriously,
we are talking about helium balloons, but they're balloons loaded with leaflets,
CDs, pen drives, dollar bills, radios,
and hundreds of other objects that help North Koreans get informed about what's
going on outside of the so-called hermit kingdom.
They're released 11 times a year by a group of North Korean defectors known as
the fighters for a free North Korea.
A group of activists led by the notorious disaster park sang hack.
The main objective of these actions is for the former fellow citizens to know
the reality of what is happening abroad and in this way,
a rod confidence in the Northern regime. Well, the last release was May 31st,
2020, and the next was scheduled for June.
And it was precisely this launched the unleashed North Korea's wrath.
But wait, just one moment. Why would something that takes.
Place 11 times a year for several years suddenly now under the communist regime
so much? Well,
right there is where the crux of the matter is.
Let's just say that theoretically,
it doesn't make much sense to derail all of the earlier advances and an issue
that after all it's not new,
what's more as a response to something that is not even the fault of the South
Korean government,
but the work of groups of defectors who do this by exercising their freedom of
speech.
But if we were also to tell you that the South Korean government itself sided
with North Korea, then this whole thing makes even less sense.
Take a look at this.
South Korea says mulling leaflet ban after Kim's sister threat France
24, and he act that she could pose a threat to the life and property of the
residents in the border area should be stopped,
said unification ministry spokesman, yo song ki youngie orders,
entry ban in border areas to block anti North leaflets.
The Korea Harold violators will be arrested on the scene and face imprisonment
of up to one year or a fine of 10 million,
one equivalent to 8,300 United States dollars under the framework act on the
management of disasters and safety.
So after years and years of being released now,
suddenly the South Korean authorities think this whole balloon thing is a clear
threat to life and property. Something that as you can probably imagine,
has not gone on noticed for many analysts and experts.
This decision violates the political freedom and freedom of expression of this
group of North Korean activists.
However, despite this,
the decision of the South Korean authorities was made after receiving these
threats from Kim Jong herself, the sister of the great leader.
Clearly speaking,
the South Korean authorities will be forced to pay a dear price.
If they let the situation go on while making these sorts of excuses,
if they fail to take the corresponding steps for the senseless act against their
fellow countrymen,
they had better get themselves ready for the possibility of a complete withdraw
of the already desolate case song, industrial park,
following the stop to tours of Mt. Coombe gong,
or shut down of the North South joint liaison office,
whose existence only as to trouble of the scrapping of the North South agreement
in the military field, which is hardly of any value. Kim [inaudible] Kim Jong.
Of course,
the rhetoric of insults and threats to the little sister Kim Joan carried out
for days was not only aimed at the South Korean government,
but also at the defectors themselves,
who they called more than just a few names, which again,
anyone with a little sister will recognize, check it out.
The human scum,
little short of wild animals who betrayed their own Homeland are engrossed in
such unbecoming acts.
They are sure to be called mongrel dogs as they bark in places where they should
not cameo jump.
To be fair. If a North Korean leader tells you this, it's sort of a compliment.
The point is.
Whole thing has generated a lot of controversy. In any case,
what has happened is that moon's government has prioritized as relations with
North Korea over political rights in the South.
That's a very controversial move. This is something to keep an eye on.
The background is more complex than it seems should a democratic government
limit as citizens rights or capacities to act in order to improve its relations
with the [inaudible] regime. That's where I leave it up to you.
We in South Korea have our own sovereignty. And in this democratic country,
people have three basic rights and one of them is freedom of speech.
If the leaflets get blocked, we will send drones. They cannot stop.
Us fact in truth cannot be stopped.
The voice of 45,000 defectors who seek truth will continue
park song, Huck, defector, and leader of the fighters for free North Korea.
In any case, the worst thing is that in the end, all of this has been fun.
Nothing.
Let's get to the most important question.
Why is Camille Jong making this play and why note let's take a look.
The empowerment of the chosen one.
We talked in a recent video about what could happen in North Korea at Kim young
earn date. And that case,
the dictator sister cameo Jones would be in pole position to be the successor
and my visual politic nerds keep one thing in mind,
although rumors of young ans death turned out to be grossly exaggerated.
The fact that this dictator is still alive doesn't mean that he may not be very
ill. You kind of know who their schools already, the regime secrecy.
Doesn't let us know for sure what's going on or what the future Kim young and
faces.
But what we can do is did you see what's going on in the regime by analyzing how
he's behaving?
And the truth is that this latest North Korean tantrum has been really very
strange and bear in mind that we're talking about North Korea as strange due to
the fact that the person chosen to shatter two years of peace talks.
Wasn't the Supreme leader, Kim young,
but his sister Kim Jong and these events can be read and several possible
ways,
Hunt and diplomatic terms.
The fact that it is Kim Jong and not Kim Jong-un who abruptly ends,
the dialogue could be a way of belittling South Korea.
That is to lower the level of importance that school apparently has for
Pyongyang after all you're Jong as an important figure and the regime,
but she is not the Supreme figure.
Therefore we could be looking at a cunning move to show that South Korea as not
as important to them as North Korea as to moon's government.
Yeah.
Okay. So this would be one possibility,
but if you look at the implications that this has for the regime itself,
there is much more to it than meets the eye with this operation.
Kim Jong demonstrates or at least may have wanted to prove that she is a strong,
determined and unscrupulous woman,
a person capable of carrying out hard setting actions without any qualms.
And this in order to present herself as number two in the regime,
or even as the possible successor as
North Korea,
there has never been the possession of deputy leader or anything resembling it.
There has never been a number two in the circle of power and the dentisty yet.
That is precisely what seems to be being built around the figure of you John,
a second figure with decisive power and capable of operating with some
independence. Kim Jong-un has not said a word throughout this entire episode.
And although he was surely the one who signed off on everything that has been
done and the eyes of his people and of the world,
the visible face has been that.
His sisters.
Tension, because that is not the end of it.
Several South Korean experts on the subject, such as we assume luck,
a former South Korean ambassador to Russia consider what North Korea has done to
actually be a very thoughtful maneuver.
So it was not to have too much prominence. And the upcoming November, 2020 U.
S election check out.
Provocations like an ICBM test could backfire.
So Kim must be thinking hard not to overplay his hand until November X
ambassador wheat.
The question you're probably asking is why,
because a major provocation for the United States could be a bit of a bonus for
Joe Biden's foreign policy planning.
And we already know that Kim Jong UN and Donald Trump get along.
Very well.
So think about it for just one moment,
repressing the launch of Intercontinental ballistic missiles or returning to the
path of nuclear testing are things that would be a direct threat to the United
States.
And obviously that could be used by Baden to attack Trump's policy towards
North Korea and possibly even to argue that Trump is the cause of North Korea,
gaining strength,
and let's not forget the huge role that North Korea has played.
And Donald Trump's foreign policy agenda.
My friend.
I just wish him well. I've had a very good relationship with Kim Jong-un.
If I weren't president you'd be in war, you would have been in war with Korea.
You would have been in war with North Korea. I wasn't president that.
I can tell you he expected that, that I can tell you. I hope he's fine.
So.
This might be a good explanation for why North Korea has chosen to blow up the
inter Korean liaison office launch a few short range missiles,
or do things like this.
North Korea, reinstalling propaganda loudspeakers, the Korea times.
Although in typical North Korea fashion,
as it turns out three days after putting up those loads speakers and without
using them at all, most of those speakers disappeared.
You see,
these are strange maneuvers that seem designed to wind up and stress mainly
South Korea and also possibly Japan, but importantly,
not uncle Sam following that logic.
It could mean that North Korea does not want under any circumstances to break
the negotiations with Washington,
but instead they want to strengthen the great leaders sister. And by the way,
sticking your finger in the eye of the South Korean government for who knows
what is something that has become almost a hobby from North Korean dictators.
But at this point,
it's up to you guys is Korea doomed to be debated forever and never reach a
mutual understanding.
What is North Korea really looking for by dynamiting peace stocks for the
umpteenth taint?
Is this all just a strategy to position Kim you're John at the top of the pale
and the event, there is a change of leadership in the near future. So as always,
please leave your answers in the comments below,
along with guesses about where is Simon,
where's this guy from and what is that accent all about little hint.
I'm not from Northern Ireland.
I'm not from Australia and I'm also not from America,
but please keep guessing because I really do find them funny. Also,
I really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit Lake, if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe. There's also the little alarm button down there,
which you can click when you want to get updates about whenever we release a new
video, don't forget to check out our friends on the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that were not my Australian former
slash Northern Ireland slash American voice. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video. Well, no,
you're never going to get something from Wales.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.